Hi so I'm super
excited to be here.
So when I was starting
college, I was super excited
because I was going to
be doing math and science
and I would just get to work
with equations and numbers
and do experiments and
play with liquid nitrogen.
And I would never have to
write anything ever again.
And I managed to
make it through,
I would say a lot of
my undergraduate career
without that being
too incorrect,
which might say something
about my scientific education.
But when I got to
graduate school,
I quickly realized that you
couldn't just do the science.
You actually also
had to talk about it.
And an excellent talk here
in this room yesterday
by Lewis Kirvan.
Sometimes you just need words.
So I was super fortunate
to have some mentors who
helped me learn how to write
and communicate, tell a narrative.
So I turned the corner and
I'm OK with writing now.
I got a lot more practice at it.
So much so now that
if you work with me,
one of the things as a part
of onboarding to work with me
is that Hadley will tell
someone that my love language is
Google Docs.
So now as Open Source
Program Director at RStudio.
Now Posit.
If you work with me, expect
to see a lot of Google Docs.
Great to have just
met you Elliot.
Expect some Google Docs.
So I'm pretty
squared away on that.
But you know, there's
still presentations
and I do like talking about
ideas, so I'll submit the talk.
I'm super excited about it.
I'll even write the talk.
And then when it comes to doing
the slides, I am never excited.
I'm never thinking like, oh,
this is going to be great.
I'm going to sit
down to do my slides.
I'll be able to put stuff
right where I want it
on the slide, my data and code.
I'll just be able to integrate
it seamlessly into my slides
and if I make any
changes, no big deal,
it'll just automatically update.
That has not once been a thought
that has gone through my mind.
Until now.
Until Quarto.
So Quarto is making
presentations fun again.
Or for me, at least
for the first time.
I am so excited about Quarto
that I would sing about it,
but that is not an area
of strength for me.
So instead I have the
words to favorite things
and I'm going to revise
these words for Quarto.
So you may be familiar with
this component of the song.
Again, not an area of strength,
but it is kind of a good tune.
So like I might accidentally
sing. So raindrops on roses
and whiskers on kittens, bright
copper kettles and warm woolen
mittens, brown paper
packages tied up with string.
These are a few of
my favorite things.
I do like most of those things,
but I do also like Quarto.
So raindrops on roses
instead of raindrops on roses
I am going to talk
about visual edits.
So I mentioned one
of the things that I
found frustrating is that
I couldn't figure out
where I'm going to put
stuff on my slides.
So this is a very
straightforward slide list item
one, two, three.
But what I want
to show you is how
I did this when I was
creating this slide.
So I have my code here.
Is this video going to play?
There we go.
So I can switch to visual.
I can see it.
Here is source or as visual.
I can add in my list item here.
Switch back to source.
There it is as source.
And then if I render
it, it's going
to render right here in preview.
So I can really integrate
where I'm writing my code
and being able to see
things right away.
So that's a really
big deal for me
because that's how I
put my slides together.
All right.
Whiskers on kittens.
Kittens are one of my favorites,
but one of my other favorites
is columns and tables.
So again, when you're
thinking about how
to construct your
slides, how you lay
things out is really important.
So if I'm thinking,
oh, what are some
of my other favorite things
besides Quarto, ice cream's,
top of the list, R and Python.
I do like both.
I'm so excited about Posit.
Least favorite things.
Banana flavor.
Fine as a banana, not a good
flavor in anything else.
I know people have different
opinions - slamming doors,
nails on chalkboards, locking
keys in the car to refer
to Julia and Max's.
I have done that.
I like still fear it actually.
So what if I wanted to
add another column, put
in an image, no big deal.
And when I say no
big deal, let's
take a look at the code that
goes along with columns.
Right this is pretty
straightforward.
We have hey, we're going
to do some columns.
And then we have the columns and
the information that's in them.
We can also change the
column width super easily.
So there's a lot of flexibility
in how we put things together.
And again, combined
with that visual editor,
let's try some stuff
out, see how it looks.
I would almost say,
like I've never
had sort of this much power
of placement in my slides
unless it was like HTML tables.
But I know we're not
supposed to compare things
to HTML, so forget I said that.
So tables.
Tables are another
thing that has never
been a joyful experience in
my presentation creation.
So this is a table.
I took some data
from scraped reviews
of ice cream from a
few different websites
and which are the most
favorite ice cream flavors.
So I took this data and
I put it into a table.
This is just a kable
table, so really
not a lot of complexity
to this table,
but integrates straight
in with my slides.
I can do a gt table.
So this is a little
cooler looking, right?
It has a little bit of
color, better formatting.
These are really some of the
fundamental things around gt.
I'm not using all the
fancy features here,
but everything that's
here is possible for you.
So what I really love
about any system.
When we talk about
being code first
and people are
talking about the UI
is what this makes possible.
So like where you can
start and then where
you can go with
things is like only
limited by your imagination
and how much time you
want to spend formatting.
So great.
My slides are doing great.
Now I'm going to have
to give my presentation.
So bright copper kettles.
I like kettles.
Fine, I guess I like tea.
I had to look up what a copper
kettle was actually, but notes
for the speaker.
So that's another thing that
you want as a presenter.
So I did mention I don't love
the presentation component,
so when I'm putting
together a talk,
I actually start with the notes.
And so it's really
nice to be able to have
those notes there for me.
And then build the
slides actually
kind of in the reverse order.
So here's just a regular sign,
a slide with Speaker notes,
slide content.
This is the code that
would generate that slide.
And then this is what it
looks like to me as a speaker.
So I have the slide
that I'm talking about,
then I have the time.
And then I have in that bottom
right where the speaker notes
go, and then my next
slide, everything that you
would hope for as a speaker.
And again, I just
really appreciate
how it's all integrated
into one document.
So you're really
working just like start
to finish in one place and
not having to context which
has been a really nice feature.
Oc and next we have
warm woolen mittens.
I like normal mittens.
My hands are always cold, so
code first keeps things stable.
It's a bit of a stretch.
Had to rhyme.
But this is really
about what I referred to
at the beginning around the
idea of reproducibility.
So as Garrick mentioned
in my introduction,
I spent many years
teaching people
about how to work with
data, and code in a research
context, good practices.
And so the
reproducibility component
is essential when we're thinking
about scientific communication.
And so within Quarto, the
slides, the figure and the code,
they're all integrated.
And so I've had situations where
I put together a presentation
and I had a figure
in that presentation.
I wanted to use
that figure again,
but I couldn't
actually remember how
I had generated that figure.
We don't have that
problem here, right?
It's all integrated together.
And so I think about sharing
things with collaborators,
but I also especially
think about sharing things
with future me because
I don't necessarily
remember what past me did
and past me doesn't always
make good choices.
And so the more I can
document, the more things
are integrated, the easier
it makes to reproduce things,
to share, to communicate
effectively and accurately
what we're doing, especially
in a research context.
So we can see here, again, this
is just straightforward ggplot
code.
And then here we have the graph
that this code generates here
below just all right, together.
So in general, right, I wouldn't
show the code necessarily along
with the figure,
but now if you go
get the slides you
have right there,
the code that went into
the figure, there's
no questions about
what it was that I
was communicating in this talk.
And you probably
really want to know
the relationship between
the average star rating
and numbers of reviews
in ice cream flavors.
I wouldn't say there's really
any positive particular trends
here.
I wouldn't do a
statistical analysis.
Ok next we come to
Brown paper packages.
And this is very apt with themes
to delight in OK so themes
to delight in again kind of
a standard, boring slide,
but we can easily
change our themes.
So I used the Super
exciting default theme
in this presentation.
Aesthetics are something
I'm working on as well,
and so you can see
that's going to work.
Yes.
But I can change the theme.
So Quarto has some built in
themes, dark being one of them.
And so you see I re-render
the theme changes.
I'm ready to go.
I'm going to try solarized,
which I actually really like.
That's another theme.
So these are the
built-in themes.
But again, if we refer back
to one of the talks yesterday
that said something
you really can
do to help yourself a
lot is to build themes
for your organization, for
yourself that you use time
and again that match
whatever it is that you need
to be doing for
your organization,
for yourself, meet whatever
standards you need.
And so you could spend a lot of
time building your own theme.
But I bet already
people in this room
are starting to
make amazing themes.
And so the opportunity to
share these with each other
and easily switch back and
forth is really meaningful
because I'm not
spending time recreating
my slides every time.
I can just change the theme and
have a different look and feel.
All right.
Finally, we're tied up with
string, and formats to share.
So tied up with string
is really the end.
Right you have
your presentation,
you need to share it.
Mine and Julie did a
great job this morning
talking about all the different
formats that you can share in.
So this here is an
HTML presentation.
That's great.
It works right in my browser.
I didn't have any
issues with that.
And it also is really
good for accessibility
because you can make
use of all the things
that are already built into HTML
around screen readers, colors,
so people are able to
make use of the settings
that they have in
their browser already.
When you're sharing
HTML, lots of times we do
need PDFs to share, distribute,
print out and carry around
with us.
So PDFs are something that is
straightforward from these as
well.
Again, all the same
document creating
all of these different formats.
And finally, I really
appreciate the work
that the Quarto team has put
into making PowerPoints.
There are a lot of organizations
that need to use PowerPoints,
so if you are in one
of those organizations,
you are probably
not culturally going
to be able to shift your
entire organization over
to using Quarto, one because
culture change is hard.
But two, there are requirements
in government agencies and drug
discovery around the kinds
of information that you share
and how you share it.
So I think what we've talked
about a lot in this meeting is
meeting people where they are,
understanding what people need
and building towards that
rather than saying like,
oh, you need to be doing
this or some idea of what's
best is really creating
opportunities for people
to do what it is they need
to do in their context.
So PowerPoint is one you
would change in that header
where we are changing the theme.
You can at the beginning say
that you want a PowerPoint
output and you can make a
PowerPoint output from within.
Quarto and again, you
have all those advantages
of being able to integrate your
code and your visualization
and you're not doing what I
did would be like, get it out
of R, put it into Illustrator,
then take it from Illustrator
and put it into PowerPoint.
So those things are at least
a little bit behind me.
But looking ahead, I'm so
excited about the opportunities
that this presents.
So here we go.
This is how we've
rewritten the Quarto song
favorite things for Quarto.
So it does rhyme.
All right.
So visual edits,
columns and tables,
notes for the
speaker codes first
keep slide stable in student
Leyden and formats to share.
These are a few of
my favorite things.
I couldn't not sing it
because I've literally
had it in my head for like
two weeks straight.
So these are some places
where you can learn more.
There's a lot of
documentation on the Quarto website.
You've been sent there for
a lot of different reasons.
Quarto presentations.
This slide deck is in GitHub.
If you want kind of
the basics of how
to get started on things,
you should subscribe
to the glimpse newsletter.
We had the first one come out
just a couple of weeks ago.
We'll have another
one in August that'll
have lots about our tools
and how to use them,
especially after this meeting.
So I'm just excited to be here.
For me, it was just such a
joy to make this presentation.
I so appreciate
the work the Quarto team
has done, how they've
listened to people like me
and thinking about how they need
to communicate their results.
And I'm just so
excited to see what
you do with Quarto,
what you share,
and what you communicate
about to make the changes that
are important in your work and
your life and your communities.
Thank you so much.